大家好,我是七华琼梦。
上一节课的话,就跟大家简单的阐述了一下,什么叫做日内交易。
那么这个概念的话,其实多数人呢,一定都是理解的,那可能有一些新手啊,可能对这个概念上会有一些混淆。
那么上节课也基本上能够给大家做了一个解释。
那么这节课之后呢,就会具体的跟大家啊,讲这个分享啊,如何做这个日内交易。
它具体是依据啊,什么来做这个日内交易的。
那么这里的话,我就必须呃,强调一下。
那么我们这个日内交易呢,也同样是依据我们七华五分钟交易系统,呃,里面的一些主要的一些,呃,理念。
尤其是我们这个军线系统,还有二博二博是军线啊,来做的一个延展,这个延伸。
呃,那么这里的话,在这个七华在这个日内交易模型里面,我用的比较多的哈,就是这个三分钟跟五分钟。
呃,所以呢,我在之后的课程里面的话,会分别从这个三分钟的这个日内交易模型,还有这个五分钟的日内交易模型啊,展开来说。
呃,那么说这个三分钟这个模型呢,呃,主要的一个依据呢,就是与这个二十日二十军线啊,作为我们主要这个交易的一个依据。
那么交易的这个要点呢,基本上,很简单啊,基本上就是线上做多啊,线下做空,上破或者下穿的手上破啊,或者下穿的时候呢进行止损或者止音。
那么这个操作的原理是很简单。呃,但是呢,在实际上的盘面上呢,呃,这个K线上穿下跳啊,然后再这样算个人的一些经验或者心理,那么可能对于你这个交易的把握,那么不同人可能会出现不同的一个结果。
但是呢,原理呢,是这样子啊,至于能不能做啊,就有各方面的因素啊,各方面的因素啊,影响了。
这里呢,就是跟大家啊,只是把这个原理啊,分散出来。呃,那么这里的话,就是要注意一下,就是在三分钟周期下的二百五十军线啊,基本上也能够作为这个周期啊,多空分界点。
呃,在两百五十军线下方,也二十军线上方做多,最好确保有一定的空间。呃,为什么这么讲呢,因为其实我们做了哈,就是我们在小周期,我们在逆大周期下期做小周期,那么经常就要考虑到这个大周期的一个阻力位置。
呃,所以说,如果说你目前坐进去的,呃,这个点位离这个阻力,离这个阻力,这个阻力位,呃,很近啊,没什么太大空间,那么你其实没有太大必要去冒这个险啊,这个就是这么个意思啊。
呃,那么同样的,就如果是在二百五十军线上方呢,那么我们也二十军线下方做空,因为是属于在这个逆这个比较大周期下去做空的。
那这个时候呢,你同样也要考虑到你做空间的一个空间大不大啊,就是可离这个盈亏比的问题。
呃,那么这里的话,我就我们继续看一下具体的一些品种的一个,一个行情,我们来看一下哈,就是一些大家可能做日内比较活跃的品种,我们先来看一下。
啊,最近活跃的品,挺活跃,就是这个橡胶,那么这个橡胶呢,就是从国庆之后呢,就走出了一波特别牛的一个行情。
啊,那么我现在看到就是橡胶的三分钟周期,我们看到哈,就是原理呢,是什么原理呢,就是说在这个二十军线上方,我们是做多。
那么如果当他这个,当他啊,吓破这个二十军线的时候呢,就进行了这个指引,就进行指引,同样的,当他吓破这个。
当他在这个,呃,就是我们这个二十军线的下方的时候呢,那么我们就去做空,他一定上破这个,上穿这个二十军线,那么我们就先进行指引,进行指引。
那么有时候呢,你像这个时候呢,我们跟他说他,就在上方我们做多,那么这种情况,那么我们做多进去,那么啊,可能到了这个,上面的这个。
这个大周期的这个主力位,那么这个时候呢,啊,那么你的空间啊,如果在这个位置上,啊,我们做日内短信的,那么你要考虑一下这个空间,你那么。
你考不考虑啊,这个空间考不考虑,如果说这个空间啊,太小,那么我们可能就没必要去考虑,因为到了这个点的时候呢,如果你没有及时出来,那可能就会马上的往下掉,所以是,为什么说我会把那个红色字体特别标注啊,在这个。
在这个军线的这个,在二百五十军线下方也二十军线上方做多啊,就要确保一定的空间,如果这个空间不够大的话,就没必要去。
去放冒差点的钱啊,没大的必要,那么想法,你如果下坡了在这个下方啊,在这个二百五十军线的下方啊,这个二十军线的下方,那么你同周期啊,同方向啊,去做空他,那么可能你的一个空间就会大得很多,空间就会大很多。
相对来讲,就是顺势啊,大小周期同周,同方向,共振的情况下,那么可能做会更好一点点。
但有时候呢,因为你,你很难,因为每一天的行情里面,啊,走出大单边的行情呢,可能会比较少,可能多数呢,属于这种啊,震荡啊,或者是震荡,然后大体方向会保持一个方向。
那这个时候呢,我们用这个二十,做日内的哈,因为日内交易的话,多数时候呢,大单边我们可能做得住,那么震荡行情呢,可能我们也能做得住。
只不过有时候呢,就比如你是为了贪一个小便宜,那么可能去做这个小,啊,这个幅度,你觉得你能够啊,接受这个小小的这个幅度,那么你跟进去之后呢,出来,啊,那么可能你交易的频率就会变得多,啊,变得多,那么如果你是相反的,你在这个同周期下,在二十军线这个这一做,那么可能你拿来的事情就可能就比较长,啊,比较长,那么你的幅度也有比较大,啊,那么这个二十军线呢,它一个好处是什么呢?
因为它能够更快的反映到它这个,它这个日内里面的一些,啊,行情的一个震荡啊,你用五分钟,呃,用五,五日军线或者是那个,啊,你用五,五军线或者是十军线,那么其实也能做,但是呢,做的就很难,因为五军线跟十军线呢,就是你的K线呢,很容易就会出现这个,呃,在这个这个这个五军线,还有这个十军线上司压法,
跳动,啊,那就很难操作,但是二十军线来讲,相对它比较
平滑,比较稳定,啊,所以基本上其实你去做这个
这个二十军线,那么其实这个幅度做日内的话,其实这个幅度也是啊,足够足够做的,只不过呢,有时候呢,呃,我们说的哈,就是我们在这个上面呢,去做,那么有时候呢,它可能会出现快速的这种
行情,那么这个时候呢,你可能就要去考虑一下了,就比如你现在是去在这个上方,你去做碰它了,它马上就反而会去
啊,反而会知道呢,啊,如果你觉得啊,你稍微有一些放松的时候呢,你可能觉得它可能还往下掉,那确实它可能往上掉,但是你觉得啊,这个这个幅度应该可以调到更多一点点,这个时候呢,你可能就拿,拿了到呢
一旦它出现了这个浮亏的时候呢,那你可能就不忍心去做子损了,那之后说呢,你就变得越扛越大越扛越大,所以为什么说很多人他认为呢,做日内交易呢,会亏钱
其实不是说这个日内交易没办法做,而是说我们的质性力没办法做到为
人性很难控制,啊,一旦我们这个日内交易的方向错了,啊,我们没有及时去做这个资损,那么可能我们就会从小,呃,从小赚变成小亏,然后呢,再慢慢的放大成这个大亏
所以呢,就是说,啊,日内交易啊,在很多人眼里呢,就是很不赞产啊,就是因为我们人性很难控,人性很难控
所以基本上就是说,你要做好这个日内交易呢,啊,有一点很重要,就是你要把你的这个交易的这个
原理,你要用机械化的动作把它给固定下来
如果你没办法把它固定下来的时候呢,你说你前许影响太大的情况下,其实说日内交易呢,其实也确实挺难成功的
挺难成功的
但是呢,如果是说你心态比较好啊,某一波你可能一天可能就做那么一波啊,做那么一波,然后用这三分钟去做,啊,那你做一波啊,我不贪啊,那么可能多数时候呢,反而是能赚钱的,反而是能赚钱的
呃,所以说
其实做日内,呃,日内交易呢,其实呃,
并不难啊,难就在很多新手呢,可能他没有这个方向啊,他也没有自己的一个交易的一些理念或者交易的系统,所以不能帮助他去呃,更好的去
开胆交易,但是一到你有的这个方向呢,其实也也不难,难的就还是在后面的一个
人性的一个
一个
管理上
呃,包括其他像中旅游是吧,中旅游
游之里面的话,中旅游也是是一个很活的一个品种,而且呢,这个他的相对来讲,啊
其实很多人还是挺喜欢做这个中旅游的,他保证金不是特别高,但是很活跃,一天
可能有一两百的这个不动的幅度啊,你就知道一个跳就是两个点,那么你一起一般一个手续费呢,可能就一跳呢,你就能够
足够你去
去去做啊,一跳就足够
像这种呢,其实啊,比较好做啊,比较好做,基本上就是
啊,你在这个
破了时候呢,去做空啊,破了这个时候,反正就是一旦啊,突破上破
那么你就去做指引啊,这个比较好
比较好,那么像这种行情,即使像这边啊,小伏震荡这种行情,那么
你在这个上方去做多,在这个破的时候呢,也去做后呢,至少也有几十个点啊,也有三四十个点的这个空间啊,四五十个点的空间
呃,四五十个点的空间,其实也是
啊,对于这种
呃,日内来讲呢,其实也是一个挺挺挺不错的这个收益了,挺不错的收益了
那你如果只是说你一天啊,打个比方,你一天做个
三次,或者做个两次,那么你每一次有100个点,200个点,100,就是有
有个四五十个点,那么你
两次交易去了,你基本上就能够有100个点,大概100个点的这个收益
啊,100个点,那么你等于是说,一手哈,一手保证金可能就6000多块钱
那么6000多块钱,你一天
呃,一手哈,6000多块钱,你一天能够赚个
呃,1000块钱,打个比方,你1万块钱,你做一手的这个重力油,那么你一天
做两次也有1000块钱,而且呢,你做的测数少,那么可能你的贩出的这个概率也就少,而且你
呃,基本上这样,你控制好的一个频率,那么你其实
呃,赚个钱还是还是风险还是挺低的,而且收益也还是不错的
实际上不错的
呃,所以有时候呢,我们做日内交易呢,我们就害怕自己,比如说你嫌弃50点不够
啊,有时候呢,那你就去会去拿,拿了之后呢,等到你这个赚钱被人家亏钱的时候呢,你又不忍得去割
啊,又不忍得去割,那么等于你这个,那你就会让他去套,啊,一套呢,没想到一套越套越大越套越大
那这个时候呢,你到底想不想执手呢
啊,那这个时候是你执手的时候,那你这个亏损的这个
这个程度呢,就远远啊,超出啊,超出的可能,所以呢,就是很多人做日内交易呢,就是
回都会在这里
啊,这是终于有
啊,那么其他那个品种呢,你也可以去看一看啊,像铁矿都把一个跳
一个跳是100块钱,那么你做这个品种呢
怎么,怎么,做这个品种呢,该不该去住啊,其实这个品种,你收入日内的细细也是有划算的
有划算的
那么在这个时候呢,像这种啊,就是你去剧都了,那么一下来啊,你做宝宝或者是啊,这个下泼这个时候呢,你去直损啊,那这个上泼
这个下泼的直损,那么这个俩好啊,你可能就会
呃
这个时候呢,如果你你单纯这个是做的时候呢,可能啊
好比较,那这个点呢,可能
可能有人去做啊,这个没问题,那么这个连续做这个直损,这个没问题
那现在这一点的话,那就不一定会
不一定真的去做了,不一定真的去做了,这个时候呢,其实呢,我们应该啊,去配合这个协律啊,我们所说的
协律,那么你一般像下的情况下呢,你就好,你就不要去做多啊,你只有在向上的时候呢,再配合去做多
那么之后呢,我们
呃,这里的话就不再单,呃,不再太详细的说啊,我们怎么样情况下能够提高这种日内交易的这种
胜率啊,这里我们在不展开,在后面的话,我们在单独的讲啊,如何去提高这个胜率啊,通过这些什么样的方式
啊,或者有一些辅助的手段,我们来
我们来提高我们日内交易的一个一个一个胜率啦
呃,那么这里的话就是这些
品种,那么呃,一样的,就是我把这个思想跟这个理念呢,就跟大家分享,那么大家可以自己根据自己去去观察
字体的这个旁边去观察,但用这个理念啊,用这个原理
用我们这个原理,你再去观察看我们这个原理啊,对你这个
交易有没有启发,那么好不好啊,这个交易系统好不好,日内交易好不好呢
我刚才说了,我只是提问一个方向,那么具体操作上,这跟你的个经验,跟你的个人的这个交易心理啊,是有很大关系的
啊,这个就个人聚集在那么其他品种的话,那么呃,你们就具体在这些,这些去根据旁边自己去观察了
反正原理呢,就按照这个原理来做
呃,这里的话,对于这个啊,具体实战方面的话,我这边就不再展开深入的了,那么之后呢,我看有没有机会啊,能够在
交易的时间里面录播啊,一段视频啊,具体用
思盘来给大家啊,讲解这个
啊,分享这个
怎么做日内交易,那么这个是,之后我们再再说,呃,那么今天这一刻的话,我们就先分享
就先
分享到这里,呃,那么现在这一刻的话,可能就会跟大家也大概聊一下这个五分钟的日内交易模型
当然这里的话就提前说一下,其实呢,就是做日内交易呢,我
更倾向用三分钟的这个日内交易模型,因为三分钟呢
它可能对日内的这个
波动的这个反应呢,会更加快速一点点,而五分钟呢
它毕竟它周期稍微长一点点,所以它这个在这个
反应的一个程度,敏感程度呢,肯定就没有三分钟那么灵感,那因为我们做这个日内呢,有时候呢
啊,你用五分,呃,用五分钟,还有三分钟,那你可能就这个
在这个世界上可能就看起来就同样
同样的就比如同样这三四个点,那么你用五分钟来看呢,可能就很短,那么你用三分钟来看呢,可能就很长
这样子的话,能够给你更加
在视觉上会有更加好的一些啊,交易的这种
呃,反应,所以呢
然后我们,呃,那时候呢,我们还是给大家也做一些五分钟方面的介绍
因为有些
一些日内一些大波段的一个机会呢,可能五分钟也会更好
或者是说在某一些时段里面,可能某一些评论呢,用五分钟的
呃,人类交易模型也可能会比较好,所以呢,也给大家做一做介绍,因为
呃,人类交易模型的话,当然
呃,其实呢,因为很多好,就说到了这个日内呢,有些人关靠盘感,他也能够做
他也能做成功,有些人关靠这个数据分析,他也能够做
呃,我这里的话,我们这个系统呢,我们都是围造这个五分钟的交易系统里面的一些核心的理念来做的
啊,因为毕竟我,我都是用这套去做交易的
呃,那么下这个就跟大家再分享这个五分钟日内交易模型
啊,如果大家有兴趣的话,那就可以再继续关注我们